from Friday prayers to Street protests
Indians in the capital New Delhi were in
no rush to obey the government's ban on
large gatherings they wanted the
scrapping of the citizenship law passed
earlier this month it paves the way for
migrants from three neighboring
countries Afghanistan Bangladesh and
Pakistan to become Indian citizens but
not if they are Muslim tens of thousands
of protesters in various parts of the
capital joined the outcry against what
they say is divisive and discriminatory
legislation by the ruling BJP Hindu
nationalist party in Delhi's jama masjid
chandra shekhar azad rawan a leader from
the Dalit party a so-called untouchable
caste waved a copy of the indian
constitution later he even read sections
from ED security forces arrived as
barricades were built government leaders
haven't officially responded to Friday's
protests protesters called for peace
harmony and non-violence I pay my
gratitude to Hindu Christian seeking
Dalit brothers who are fighting this
battle alongside us I also want to tell
it to the people here who make this
rally a success by protesting peacefully
and being united in the northern city of
Lucknow the capital of Uttar Pradesh
police fought with protesters 24 hours
after one person was killed two others
were killed in karnataka state a ban on
large gatherings has been imposed in
both states the port city of Mangalore
and karnataka remains under curfew till
sunday more protesters waited until late
evening to join in demonstrations turned
violent in Delhi as police used water
cannons against the protesters people we
talked to earlier today said that they
had come to the streets to protest not
only against the citizenship law but
also to stand up for India's secular
Constitution more protests are planned
in the coming days Sabinas Russia
al-jazeera
New Delhi